François Mitterrand pour sa part indique
qu'il attend la visite que doit lui
rendre demain matin le président du
Conseil constitutionnel Roger frais
avant de répondre à la lettre de
Monsieur Giscard d'Estaing François
Mitterrand précise qu'il prendra sa
décision pour rentrer à l'Élysée en
fonction des avis du président du
Conseil constitutionnel cet après-midi
François Mitterrand a reçu les membres
du comité de soutien à sa candidature
une rencontre que François Mitterrand
avait voulu avant tout amical sourire et
bousculade des vedettes du spectacle des
écrivains des scientifiques mais aussi
des compagnons de la vie politique à
tous le nouveau président est venu dire
merci pour ce réseau d'énergie et
d'amitié à tous François Mitterrand a
demandé de poursuivre l'action pour le
président élu comme il l'avait fait pour
le candidat
vous avez donc été témoin acteur
pionnier je voudrais un grand merci et
je suis venu simplement pour cela dans
votre présence je trouverai de nouvelles
raisons d'énergie et de foi dans
l'action qui m'attend d'autant plus que
ce n'est ni un bonjour ni à nous revoir
nous sommes appelés les uns les autres à
mener notre chemin au temps qu'il le
faudra au niveau qui remet c'est-à-dire
de la responsabilité du pays mais je ne
la confisque pas à moi seul cette
responsabilité elle est partagée par les
citoyens citoyennes citoyens celles et
ceux qui veulent participer à
l'édification de ce qui n'est pas une
expérience mais de ce qui s'appellera je
vais faire l'histoire l'histoire de
France
François Mitterrand pour sa part indique
qu'il attend la visite que doit lui
rendre demain matin le président du
Conseil constitutionnel Roger frais
avant de répondre à la lettre de
Monsieur Giscard d'Estaing François
Mitterrand précise qu'il prendra sa
décision pour rentrer à l'Elysée en
fonction des avis du président du
Conseil constitutionnel cet après-midi
François Mitterrand a reçu les membres
du comité de soutien à sa candidature
une rencontre que François Mitterrand
avait voulu avant tout amical sourire et
bousculade des vedettes du spectacle des
écrivains des scientifiques mais aussi
des compagnons de la vie politique à
tous le nouveau président est venu dire
merci pour ce réseau d'énergie et
d'amitié à tous François Mitterrand a
demandé de poursuivre l'action pour le
président élu comme il l'avait fait pour
le candidat
acteur pionniers je vous devais un grand
merci et je suis venu simplement pour
cela dans votre présence je trouverai de
nouvelles raisons d'énergie et de foi
dans l'action qui m'attend d'autant plus
que ce n'est ni un bonjour ni un au
revoir nous sommes appelés les uns les
autres à mener notre chemin au temps
qu'il le faudra au niveau qui revient
c'est-à-dire de la responsabilité du
pays mais c'est de la confisque pas à
moi seul
cette responsabilité elle est partagée
par les citoyens citoyennes citoyens
celles et ceux qui veulent participer à
l'édification de ce qui n'est pas une
expérience mais de ce qui s'appellera je
vais faire l'histoire l'histoire de
France